[Applause]
how
are you huh oh i'm sorry i have to wait
till they all finish cheering cheer some
more everybody
there you go
thank you you don't you're not you don't
have a shyness thing or a modesty thing
at all
can you imagine you like that you like
that a lot how are you you look good
thanks i feel good yeah you look
terrific i have i want to
talk about something right here at the
top and then we'll talk about saturn out
live that you're hosting which is i
think really exciting yeah it's going to
be a great show
but i want to say the last time i saw
you
lisa and i have been friends for years
she may deny it but we've been friends
for like 10 years
last time i was in los angeles to do the
tonight show
i want to stop by and see you so i
stopped by on the set right
of the movie that you're shooting with
mira sorvino right
all right and you had a little game boy
that you were playing with yes
and at one point you hand it to me and
you say can you hold this
while i shoot this scene with mira
sorvino yes so i suddenly become the
nerd who holds the game boy
while you're shooting a movie i have to
put you in your place yeah
very good it worked all right so i'm
sitting there no she's right i really do
oh no no but i'm sitting there holding
the game boy like oh i'll just like
looking like a freak just holding it
while
the big stars are doing their movie and
then i have to go because i got to go to
the tonight show and the scene's going
on for quite a while
so i put the game boy down yeah whatever
yeah and i
you got to hear this because this is a
bit of a problem here i put the game boy
down and i tell somebody uh that's lisa
kudos game boy i gotta go if she needs
it
i guess the person didn't work on the
movie and i caused a huge incident
because later i'm in burbank i'm about
to do the tonight show
like 40 people come rushing up to me and
say where is lisa kudrow's game boy
and it creates this huge agents are
involved people are screaming where is
it
what have you done who the hell do you
think you are i was beaten up at one
point
it was just this whole incident i'm like
what was the big deal
it was my game boy well what
you know but i had also for like the
next like two or three hours after you
left i had people coming up to me like
okay we're trying to find your game boy
um you know really serious you know it's
like right
we think we've tracked it to uh jay leno
uh
we've got someone on it and i can't tell
you how i'm sorry i am
i was like all right no i but i mean it
was like this was i thought an
indication of how successful you are
what a big story you become if i lose
something i could lose my spleen
i couldn't get anyone to go looking for
it you know there'd be no one like just
find it yourself all righty movies do
that
oh okay it's such a much bigger deal
yeah on the show it's
a little better wow
all right no you do that's so cool it's
uh everything's going well and yeah i
gotta mention uh
i i want to talk to you because i've
known you for so long
i i met you i didn't meet your husband
for a while you know because i didn't
get out to los angeles i finally
met your husband he's a really cool nice
guy yeah his name is michelle
he's a frenchman yeah yeah but he's like
i i didn't know what to expect when i
heard when you told me
i married a frenchman i expected beret
he's riding a bicycle he's wearing a
striped shirt
there's a big french roll in the seat
you know and he's
and he does all that it's you know he
does that he does he walks
with a big baguette all the time
yeah he's the real cliche yeah but he's
uh
he talks like pepe le pew which i
thought was really stunning
but what's he he does seem like a very
nice guy though he is he's as sweet as
pie
he's great he's great and yeah things
are going well
you guys oh things are going great it's
things are going really great he's
really happy
it's like now he can finally relax
because we got married and now he gets
his green card yay
and um well it's really stressful i mean
he don't he would always complain about
how immigration is very stressful
thing to deal with and i i would think
what a wimp come on just like
you know big deal just always like
nervous about the big interview
big deal you might get kicked out of the
united states and never be able to
return what's your problem
yeah it is a big deal but just like
having to deal with these people he'd
always say they're difficult they're so
mean to you and you know
like oh my god you're so paranoid you
know wouldn't validate it at all
so we go in for our meeting and i'm just
he's really nervous and i couldn't be
more relaxed i don't care
when's this going to be over i have to
go to work and
we go in there and they really are
scary mean people really we sit down and
and and the man says um okay so i need
some id please
and he's just like staring sort of dead
at you like you're about to pull
something on me and i'm gonna catch it
like okay so michelle hands over his id
and then i hand
my purse had just gotten stolen so i
didn't actually
have a picture id and um i said well
i've got like a credit card and this
stuff he's like
this is not the same name as your
husband's right i was like no i have to
keep my name for my career and he was
like
what would that be and
he hadn't seen the show or anything i
guess not i said well i'm an actor and
he's like
all right whatever okay um and i thought
wow this is gonna be really tricky
i had no picture id i he wanted to see
mail
my mail doesn't come to our address so
it doesn't even look like we have the
same address
and i for could not prove who i was and
he wouldn't believe it and we
finally whipped out like magazine
articles and stuff you know they're
like we have this and
here i'm on the cover of people magazine
look at that i'm the wedding gown and
he's with me
and the guy was just like i'm sorry what
what would have i would i have seen you
in anything
i said a tv show friends and he went oh
all right oh i've seen that well that
makes things a little bit
well okay all of a sudden it was like a
party
and
[Laughter]
it's true like the friends theme kicked
in and you were all dancing in a
fountain
really yeah we all became named
you have to say the word anymore do you
know that no oh no you have to say the
word you just go oh yeah no i'm
we're close we've become really good
[Laughter]
you use that to communicate now with
people communicate in music
a new level of psychosis all right well
let's talk about this saturn out live
this week this is this is great you're
perfect to do this i knew you
for years doing sketches in the
groundlings and everything like that i'm
really excited you're doing it
yeah me too except what i realized is
the stuff i did in the groundlings
mm-hmm that
doesn't wouldn't work well on saturday
night it doesn't actually work well
what do you mean well my characters were
so like sarah night live is like fun
broad happy
characters all my stuff was like i did
like my
favorite character was like an actress
on a talk show you know i mean i did
that stuff
right right you know that's not a good
funny that's not a good character
for certain i think mean i just i
thought it was
funny at the time but it's just kind of
like you know like a low-key character
who's just
well i'll do it for you if you want yeah
let's see it
so this is the name so the name of the
character is is actress on a talk show
yeah i was very creative with my
character name good name okay but she
was just really phony and like hello
hello oh hello
hello you know that's all she would say
and like yeah it's been a long time
since i've you know done anything i
guess um but
um just because of the surgery i had and
thanks for all the cards and letters you
sent
and um really helped it really did thank
you
you know and then you just like pursue
what what happened to her why she had
surgery and she's like well
oh all right i had had a severe
tonsillitis
and no and they added they had to
actually remove
both both of my tonsils
yeah no it's hard it's about who am i
now you know
this is a you don't know how often i'm
sitting here with people that are
actually
like that i know i've always been afraid
to yeah i really am that's what my life
is like
all right this is i'm really i'm really
looking forward to this i think a lot of
people are of course friends thursday at
eight o'clock on nbc as if i had to
mention it and you're hosting sarna live
this week with measle guest
sheryl crow and i think that's very cool
yeah lisa thanks so much for coming back
thank you
we love having you lisa kudrow everybody